katia alors vous avez peut-être vous
suivi je sais pas où vous étiez place et
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé ces
petites tensions que l'on a décrit à
l'instant ça c'est vraiment tendu oui
oui en effet il ya des certains
manifestants se sont approchés des
barrages de forces de l'ordre et ont
commencé à jeter des pavés des cailloux
toutes sortes de projectiles et là il
avait auparavant au rang des affaires
renversé une voiture facialement puis à
puis également brûlé du mobilier urbain
il ya un feu là en ce moment donc sur
des sur cet espace des invalides sur les
côtés les contre allées et puis
évidemment la charge n'a pas trier plus
dur charge de gaz lacrymogène assez
important donc tout le monde s'est mis à
courir évidemment là le calme est revenu
partiellement mais fera donc le gros de
la manifestation reste sur les ca des
invalides tout à fait calme n'est même
pas au courant mais apparaît derrière
les arbres évidemment il ya eu des
échauffourées un peu plus sérieuses avec
les bars de l'ordre juste un mot
peut-être katia pique nique sur le
dispositif de sécurité qui a été
déployée aujourd'hui pour encadrer cette
manifestation pacifique un normalement
leur appel à des personnels soignants
oui à la fête magnifique a en effet été
déclaré en tout cas pas des invalides
est bouclée assure surtout tes côtés
donc on peut on peut évidemment certains
parce que sur certains barrages il y ait
des affrontements oui mais bon
évidemment cette manifestation est
totalement pacifique un l'aller les gens
sont en train d'avancer avec la musique
les drapeaux en fait donc tout se passe
bien il ya eu peu de moments en effet de
deux temps sur les forces de l'ordre
quand je vous disais projectiles avec
deux dés des gaz lacrymogènes ont
vraiment de venir à des prix sans fin
donc on a toutes et tous ces parfaits
lacrymogènes vraiment loin à la ronde
je le disais katia ceux qui participent
à cette grande manifestation cette
grande journée de mobilisation à paris
mais aussi dans toute la france ce sont
principalement les personnels soignants
est-ce qu'à paris là où il ya eu
ces petites tensions qu'on a pu observer
que l'on a décrit est ce que vous avez
pu vous observez d'autres des individus
par exemple un peu plus radicalisés qui
se sont créés au sein de cette
manifestation
mais on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'y ait
que du personnel soignant il ya
énormément de syndicats il ya énormément
de ya des élus aussi et il ya des
citoyens qui sont venus le plaider
soutenir les soignants après en effet ya
des certainement des éléments des black
blocks 1 sans aucun doute aussi qui
viennent manifester aussi dans cette
manifestation autorisée
il ya deux ans fait cela vous voulez les
blouses blanches on les voit pas bien
plus dense mais il ya énormément
d'autres défaillances
on voit aussi des gilets jaunes aussi
manifesté 4 7 me les donne en effet on a
pu relever des remous y est il ya
énormément de dix maisons dans l'entente
à année pendant par les chansons des
gilets jaunes également ya des fumigènes
jaune
oui en fait que ce flot ya une forme de
convergence des luttes le théâtre du
soleil aussi donc bien sûr ils viennent
tout à pied des soignants ne peut pas
dire que c'est uniquement une
manifestation de femmes que pour les
soignants et leur [ __ ] des [ __ ] de
toute nature sauvage y compris l'on vole
un peu tous types de manifestants alors
nous on voit sur ces images katia on
voit toujours ces images en direct de
tension avec des gaz lacrymogènes les
forces de l'ordre qui intervienne
justement pour repousser les
manifestants a qui vont un peu trop loin
on voit des sept certains individus
lancé des pierres en tout cas
on voit que c'est quand même assez
tendue sur cette journée de mobilisation
se déroule quand même dans un contexte
particulier on a en plein c ur de la
santé vous la verrez tout à l'heure mais
on est aussi c'est vrai dans un contexte
de dénonciations internationales
des violences policières et de racisme
présumées au sein des forces de l'ordre
aussi à l'eau oui katia je sais pas si
vous m'avez entendu oui oui oui un biais
des mois oui oui alors en était là en
revanche on ne voit pas de type de
banderoles u2 devant aujourd'hui un
parce que tu es tu es vraiment très
focalisée dans l'attenté là je pense que
tout le monde tout le monde et de tête
aller aujourd'hui en revanche bien sûr
il ya aussi des personnes qui font
avancer leurs craintes et revendications
parfois de manière aussi violente en
revanche montois en gros si vous voulez
de matam d'aventuriers un cortège de
soignants gvt et des des accords
définitifs outils pour accompagner les
soignants ça s'est passé vraiment dans
le calme
là maintenant voyez il ya le mobilier
urbain qui brûle en face d'une prise de
colonne de feu extrêmement
impressionnant tant ça brûle beaucoup il
ya des militants de tous bords de ce
syndicat va avec pastore bellion voit
maintenant le le mot d'ordre benneteau
l'a entendu des chansons antipolis était
quand même majoritairement la santé
aujourd'hui un oui oui c'est la santé
oms on l'a bien compris katia technique
c'est une journée aussi particulière
parce que il ya cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire qui doit débuter à
l'assemblée nationale
le premier entendu à 17 heures eh bien
ce sera jérôme salon le directeur
général de la santé katia alors qu'on
voit qu'on a l'impression que ça se tend
de plus en plus raconté nous dites nous
quelle atmosphère là bas écoutait ya des
gens qui applaudit pas à mesure que le
feu est en train de prendre et à des
personnes qui montent autour du mot
venir 28 autres qui fiche moi là on a en
effet il ya toute une partie des
manifestants les clients ont eu tort de
en attendant tu as fait avec avec la
folie train pour le moment disons que là
il ya toute cette fumée à très épaisses
noires et a énormément de personnes avec
des capuches voilà qui est en train de
suivre
mais là pour le moment la colonne de crs
ne bouge par ailleurs y'a pas encore y'a
pas de nouvelles charges pour le moment
mais les les rangs des manifestants on
va de ces manifestants furent admis côté
s'est rapproché en fête du feu donc je
pense qu'on peut s'attendre à une autre
charge d'impôt est le parcours
john de cette manifestation à paris
particulièrement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler le l'objectif de ce
parcours alors le vieux
en tout cas le parcours fait de pouvoir
faire attendait parce qu'elle est enfin
recommence à courir
elle était donnée de faire impression
donc d'un ministère de la santé des
cortèges sont partis d'un peu partout
nous avons subi à celui de l'hôpital
saint louis
mais là ils viennent en fait faire
pression auprès d'eux d'abord évidemment
en passant devant le ministère de la
santé
c'est en tout en venant aux invalides
avec l'idée de faire pression sur le
ségur ces fameuses négociations avec des
syndicats des coordinations de soignants
pour raccorder ces fameuses
revalorisations de salaires l'arrêt des
fermetures de lits et tout ça au
qu'aujourd'hui
monde était vraiment déterminé à achever
à choisir deux itinéraires pour rappel
au ségur et pour faire pression sur le
ministère de la santé au moment des
négociations
le cortège et les parties de l'hôpital
saint louis alors il est pas en fait un
cortège est parti de l'hôpital
saint-louis là c'était vraiment
organiser parce que des des associations
étaient venus soutenir les soignantes
l'hôpital saint louis
mais si vous voulez les syndicats ont
organisé leur propre leur propre cortège
bon sauf que celui de saint louis a
décidé d'emprunter les rues s'est fait
très vite stoppée en fait par les forces
de l'anp tu es donc le tout le monde a
été on a été obligé de prendre le métro
alors à l'écouté là il ya des prises de
parole des syndicats
parce la voyez les syndicats prennent la
parole et ce en train de dire que le
thème la manifestation sport c'est pas
bon pour pour la manifestation en fait
qui disent que leur s'attendait je les
écoute
ou alors que nourrit alors ils disent
qu'ils se plaignent en fait les mets
syndicats se plaignent de prendre les
canons à eau
les manifestants donc je fais face ils
vont maintenir ma fille bobbi non pas à
la red bull ne reçoit fabre si vous
voulez et s'inquiètent aussi du tour que
prend la manifestation les affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre
voila voila on voit de toute façon nous
les forces de l'ordre intervenir là où
vous regardez les images qui nous
parviennent en tout cas comme cela ce de
l'ordre interviennent du
aux radicaux qui sèment le trouble en
marge de cette manifestation des
personnels soignants des syndicats et
cela à l'appel de collectifs aussi de
soignants manifestation donc à paris
mais aussi on le rappelle dans toute la
france et une manifestation qui était au
départ pacifique qui se déroule en plein
ségur de la santé donc katia vous avez
peut-être pu écouter ce que disent les
syndicats qui s'inquiètent de la suite
alors deux seules arrivées inquiète mais
hier on ne trouve pas la réaction
policière disproportionnée rebond après
ils n'ont pas exactement vu depuis fin
février ont vu c'est qu'il ya eu des
jets de lacrymogènes
apparemment des cannois où tu te d'antan
mais moi je n'en ai pas vu mais bon en
tout cas c'est aujourd'hui et il ya
énormément de jets de lacrymo voilà ça y
est tu as commencé il ya une nouvelle
charge donc là les manifs et sans
tendance et avoir des limites
en fait les manifestants sont en train
de courir un buzz blanche les éléments
radicaux de ce que vous voulez tout d'un
coup être facile à une nouvelle ça qui
reposent les manifestants vers le pont
alexandre iii
donc en effet oui je pense que tu avais
erreur ça c'était assez violent pour une
manifestation de poignant ça prend un
tour assez défavorable en tout quatre
ans qu'elle soit n'en veulent pas
abandonner leur manifestation c'était le
sens de des prises de parole en ce
moment sur sur le terrain donc cette
grande manifestation cc on peut dire que
c'est l'une des grandes manifestations
depuis
l épidémie de coronavirus et les
annonces dimanche soir d'emmanuel mâcon
la vie est censé reprendre son cours
progresser dans tout le pays
on ne s'attendait pas katia pique nique
à ce que cette manifestation on peut le
dire dégénère ainsi on voit sur ces
images encore des manifestants courir
pour échapper aux charges des forces de
l'ordre et on voit ce nuage épais de gaz
lacrymogène également cette humanité qui
était autorisé vous qu'on dit au ps le
ballet soient respectés de dents en or
on en effet latin ça prend un tour en
quelques secondes qui voyant boîte plus
à l'est près des invalides est
entièrement recouvert de fumée et les
lacrymo tout le monde est en train de
pleurer de honte et docks a en effet été
c'est très surprenant pour une
manifestation de patienter en effet il
me dit qu'un tel le degré d'inconfort
on va rejoindre katia on va vous
retrouver tout à l'heure vous continuez
de suivre donc ces tensions en marge
cette manifestation grande mobilisation
aujourd'hui des personnels soignants à
l'appel des syndicats et des collectifs
des hôpitaux on va rejoindre nadège
abderrazak qui suit avec vous également
le cortège
nadège vous vous êtes vous au coeur donc
du cortège et vous suivez cette tension
également quels sont vos observations et
et quels sont vos informations également
écouter à samantha cette manifestation
elle avait plutôt bien commencé ils
étaient plusieurs dizaines de milliers à
être partie au départ du ministère de la
santé pour demander plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital public
elle a dégénéré en tête de cortège vous
le voyez peut-être derrière moi sur ces
images de julien de la cour 1 on a déjà
forces de l'ordre qui a bien procédé à
des tirs de gaz lacrymogène on a des
voitures des barrières qui ont été
incendiés on constate de fortes tensions
à ce niveau là l'apparition des pompiers
qui viennent à d'intervenir
voilà donc on a des médecins des aides
soignants des infirmières au coeur de
cette manifestation on a aussi des
policiers qui sont venus soutenir en
civil un set cette mobilisation du
personnel soignant et c'est compliqué
parce qu'on a aussi est bien repéré
quelques quelques mètres de là la
présence de personnes masquées habillés
de noir donc voilà quelques tensions
alors de cette manifestation en tête de
cortège ça se passe un peu mieux
de l'autre côté où lé syndicat sont
présentés dans l'indication elles sont
les mêmes cette colère des aides
soignants du personnel hospitalier elles
datent pas d'hier elle date de plusieurs
mois maintenant 14 15 mois de grèves de
manifestations
et puis cette colère et bien elle a pris
un ton aaa
elle a empiré avec l'apparition du
coronavirus cette crise sanitaire
puisque ces aides soignants et bien il
était en première ligne
les russes se sont sentis abandonnés par
le gouvernement donc voilà ce qu'ils
réclament un parmi les principales
revendications c'est une augmentation de
salaire pour eux pour tous
300 euros de plus par mois pour
s'aligner sur la moyenne européenne ils
demandent également à des créations à
des créations de postes et l'arrêt des
fermetures d'établissements de services
de lydie 7500 lits ont disparu au cours
des six dernières années donc voila vous
le voyez peut-être derrière nous on a un
nuage de gaz lacrymogène qui flatte ici
donc on voit là les lélés les roches
plus que je peux vous dire c'est que la
tension elle est toujours aussi un
palpable les syndicats se sont réunis
pour discuter voir si la manifestation
cette mobilisation se poursuit comme il
était prévu pour rejoindre l'assemblée
nationale ou si il est temps peut-être
de raccrocher en tout cas voilà ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que la tension
est palpable
ici dans dans cette manifestation du
personnel hospitalier
merci beaucoup nadège on
vous allez continuez donc à suivre cette
manifestation peut être qu'on entendra
aussi votre micro dé des manifestants
alors qu'on voit ici donc un important
cordon de sécurité qui encadre donc
cette manifestation derrière et bien les